hey there welcome this is our third show
from the Largo theater and we're
shooting from this theater in what we
think is a very responsible way
medically I only have a few crew members
with me they're all socially distanced
they're all wearing masks now I do want
to talk about something that is well no
way around it quite tragic as of this
taping as you know there have been over
three million confirmed cases of kovat
19 in the United States and over a
hundred and thirty three thousand deaths
of course each of those numbers is a
person and one of those people just
happens to be the mother of one of my
writers Lorri Kilmartin Lorri shared her
experiences watching her mother leave
this world on Twitter it's been getting
a lot of attention each of the tweets
she wrote even the funny ones are of
course heartbreaking I haven't seen Lori
since we stopped filming at Warner
Brothers in March but I wanted to talk
to her and let her share her devastating
experiences with you a lot of people
were really drawn to your you're a very
precise way of expressing pain but also
making it funny at the same time and and
very human and nobody does that quite
like you and and some of the tweets were
really pretty remarkable I was reading
them and as your mom was passing away
and I would find myself laughing but
also understanding how much you loved
your mom you watch that you walk this
tightrope which is really fascinating
yeah I guess you know like every comic
like you don't like to sit in a feeling
too long you know you like to pull
yourself out of it and the best way for
us to do it is right a little joke about
it and also weirdly I had already done
this with my dad when he died of lung
cancer
I at that time I didn't want to leave
his bedside he was doing
Hospice and the whole family was around
him so I was just sort of tweeting a
little jokes about what it was like and
so I I you know have a specialty now and
we'll probably never find gloves because
why would you want to enjoy my family
but for me to find some meaning in it
and also I I didn't feel like people
knew an F wet echo bit death was like
and how strange and surreal and awful it
is um you're there are a couple of would
you mind sharing a couple of the tweets
with us yeah okay
my sister and I are both heartbroken
that mom's last words to us were
complaints about the nursing home and
not about our appearance I just left a
one-star yelp review of the skilled
nursing facility where my mom taught
cope at 19 yeah that seems like a
well-deserved one suicide oh wow
okay this brings up something that I
wanted to talk to you about the the the
covet pandemic has somehow improbably
become now a political issue which it
really shouldn't be I don't think but
your mom was an avid Trump supporter and
that was one of the areas of conflict
between the two of you but she sort of
learned to coexist with that is that
right yeah
but also I do you know I regret that I
let it get on my head so much because I
do think it affected you know the last
year or two I had with Dierks I was so
enraged I would blame her for policies
that she didn't know about you know when
I when I looked at the media she was
consuming she didn't know they were
happening so yeah that but that made
things more awkward for sure your mom's
situation
was tragic all of these deaths are
tragic but your mom was negative for quo
vid you guys have been very careful
about clove it and then she had to go
into a nursing home where she contracted
Club 8 is that right right she was
hospitalized for shortness of breath she
was in port health you know and she
might have died this year anyway but she
after she got she was removed from the
hospital and taken to a skilled nursing
facility so she could just give a little
bit of her strength back and that's
where she caught Cove it it's like one
person got it and then with just it was
crazy
so she was hospitalized and then after
about a week maybe there are a lot of
people out there that hear about kovat
people passing away from Cove aid but
they don't really know what it's like
it's in your experience a particularly
cruel way to die it's awful and I have
the comparison of my father because he
did home hospice it was nine days of him
at home we were all with him the entire
time we had friends coming by that tell
them what they loved about him it was
like a parade and a celebration of his
life my mom didn't get to have any last
words
the Kovan like took her to a place where
she couldn't speak almost immediately
she was alone in a room the people that
came in to take care of her were dressed
head-to-toe and plastic you could barely
even see people's eyes she didn't know
them we watched on an iPad and we were
also lucky that this hospital had been a
hot spot in March so they had iPad set
up in all the rooms and we don't have to
share a connection with anybody so after
we visited my mom we headed back to my
house
and we left the connection open for 70
hours until she died and you know she's
just on my iPad and I just take her
around the house and we'd be talking to
her all the time and I put her next to
me
we fell asleep and woke up and check to
see that she's still breathing and said
hello to her and said you know we were
just kind of saying hey we're here mom
we're watching you you know we're making
eggs this is we just got a puppy this is
our puppy and we just kind of we
included her and everything we were
doing and I think that was so important
and I hope that families that are going
to right now get to experience something
like that it's really important for you
to go to let go and it's so important
for for that person you know I mean
people a lot of the attitude has been
well everyone's old anyway so who cares
well first they're not a lot of young
people are dying in and you know old
people don't deserve to go out this way
like you just don't it's awful it's not
fair to them and it's in it's so much of
it's unnecessary if we just done the
right thing early on you know my mom in
terrible health but she'd at least be
here and and if she were going to die
this year he's surrounded by us and it
would be a good normal and normal death
like my dad had what do you say to a lot
of people out there who refuse to wear
masks what do you say to them it's you
know what we should say is a mask will
protect you what I think our huge
mistake was telling Americans a mask
will protect somebody else we're pretty
selfish people we don't care about other
people so let's let's pivot and just say
a mask will protect you from an awful
death and maybe that'll turn things
around you know yeah I have to ask this
because I've known you for a long time
should I god forbid anything should
befall me sometime the near future you
have jokes ready to go for the death of
Conan O'Brien have you already if you
have you've already written them or do
you think you could access them pretty
easily oh yeah the whole whole writing
staff we contribute to a Google Doc
every single day we're we're so ready
for you to die the shame you're still
here because the country really needs
our job
you know what I have to say I've had a
great life I'd like it to last a lot
longer but when I go I would be honored
to have craft some just amazing jokes
about my passing because I would like
people to laugh let's hope it's not for
you know at least at least 600 years
yeah I am I'm really sorry that you that
you lost your mom and and in this way
that frankly just is terrible
and you know you're one of my favorite
people and you're one of my favorite
comedy minds and also you're such a good
person that you didn't deserve this your
mom didn't deserve this but you have a
lot of people around you as you know
that love you and we care about you and
you're fired right after the death of
your mom and you know and here on zoom'
on television I'm just you know I'm just
not liking the work I'm seeing lately
you think I'm gonna get a lot of public
support for this move I do I really do
well I miss seeing you in person I like
our zoo and I wish you and your family
the best during this difficult time and
like I say yeah you're fired thank you
you're one of my favorite people to all
right well take care and I'll see you
soon